on a un plan de match solide avec cet
enjeux qui sont clairs sur lesquels on
va plancher dans les prochains mois et
les prochaines années on veut faire une
différence on va ministre de l'Éducation
de François Legault avec ses sept
priorités pour remettre le système
québécois sur les rails Bernard
Drainville a de grandes ambitions comme
on l'entendait en entrevue un peu plus
tôt mais peut-il réussir là où tant
d'autres ont eu en difficulté voyons
voir ce qu'on pense mes collaborateurs à
les castonguettes animateurs de midi
info ici première et chronicard au
Toronto magazine d'actualité Michel CEG
est analyste politique à La Presse et
Radio-Canada bonjour à vous trois
bonjour
alexiée les bonnes priorités monsieur
Drainville cette semaine
je pense que oui je pense qu'il a
identifié évidemment il y a tellement de
priorités
retrouvent pas même si ça reste une
priorité de François Legault mais oui je
pense qu'on a mis le doigt sur les
bonnes priorités deux en particulier que
je trouve intéressantes la valorisation
des diplômes d'études professionnelles
les DEP c'est vrai qu'on les a le nom
longtemps négligées alors qu'on a
beaucoup besoin de ce type de diplôme là
au Québec l'idée aussi d'amener un autre
adulte par classe au primaire les
services de garde pour le faire sur
cette intéressante aussi je crois par
contre qu'il sous-estime
s'attache du côté de ce qu'on appelle
l'école à trois vitesses le privé les
programmes particulier dans les écoles
publiques donc en art robotique en sport
etc et ce qu'on appelle donc le régulier
comme Bernard draville le dit les
enfants qui sont dans rien de sondage
aucun programme en particulier il dit il
faut étendre les programmes particuliers
à l'ensemble du Québec il y en a
davantage au public oui mais on ne
pourra pas envoyer tous les enfants dans
des programmes particuliers il va
inévitablement y avoir une forme de
sélection on fait pas multiplier les
programmes à l'infini on n'a pas les
ressources pour la faire on n'a pas le
personnel pour le faire il va toujours
rester un certain nombre d'étudiants de
jeunes dans les classes de rien dans le
régulier et il faudra trouver de manière
de valoriser ses classes là de valoriser
cet enseignement là et donner à ceux qui
sont dans leur régulier la chance comme
les autres d'étudier dans ce qu'ils
veulent même si c'est à l'université où
on se rend assez peu nombreux quand on
est au régulier à l'université donc ça
c'est une grosse tâche et le ministre
semble peut-être mal mesuré l'ampleur de
cette tâche là mais en général c'est un
premier gel ça va se bonifier je pense
qu'il y a identifier de plutôt bonne
priorité
c'est mieux d'identifier des priorités
que de pas en avoir alors c'est un
premier pas dire qu'on a un plan de
masse solide quand on est un peu dans le
flou même sur le nombre d'enseignants
qui travaillent
on n'est pas mettons qu'on n'est pas
rendu on a tous découvert quelque chose
qu'on pouvait soupçonner c'est que les
gouvernements pas seulement celui du
québecifères en l'absence de donner dans
la brume c'est quand même extraordinaire
en 2023 d'entendre ça ça donne une idée
là que c'est pas seulement les facs et
les machines qui sont d'un autre siècle
c'est le mode de fonctionnement au
niveau de la collecte de données et de
ce qu'on en fait pour évaluer les
problèmes mais sur les programmes
particuliers des fois on peut se
demander si c'est pas le programme
régulier qu'on devrait améliorer je
soupçonne que mon amie Auger et moi
avons tous les deux étaient des élèves
qui étaient dans le programme de rien et
et on n'a pas trop mal réussi dans la
vie mais le fait est que ce qui était
solide c'était le programme régulier
c'était pas les options inexistantes
dans mon corps en Ontario de toute façon
à l'époque en français alors peut-être
que dans ce cas-ci on met l'enfer aux
mauvais endroit donc au lieu de détendre
le programme de porien à tout le monde
peut-être bonifier le programme de c'est
vrai que ça fait encore mais monsieur de
rêver nous disait cette semaine encore
une réflexion autour de son vers un
Michel on évalue son on va évaluer son
succès commun à Bernard Drainville
écoutez c'est des promesses tellement
vague des têtes de chapitres tellement
vague que n'importe quoi peut être une
réussite mais bon tout le monde
s'attendait à ce qu'ils disent au même
problème avec la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre le dire c'est une priorité
c'est pas la régler ça
et dans plusieurs de ces domaines là on
sait pas exactement où le gouvernement
ça va l'école à trois vitesses c'est un
bon exemple ils ont décidé avant même
que Monsieur David soit nommé à ce
ministère là qu'on allait pas toucher à
ça dans la campagne électorale alors on
peut toujours essayer de se trouver de
la marge de manœuvre puis je me suis en
train de penser que j'ai bien réussi à
la vie mais dans le temps il y avait
deux il y avait deux voies il y avait le
privé il y avait le public avait été des
écoles de rien c'est arrivé relativement
récemment c'est assez spécialisations là
on les a pas encore bien d'évacués c'est
pas encore quelque chose que d'autres
aussi ça marche de façon
quotidienne mais est-ce que ça donne
plus de diplômes universitaires est-ce
que ça donne plus de gens qui sont qui
sont qui seront par exemple dans un
cours professionnel ça c'est un priorité
de gens quand c'est devenu Paris Premier
ministre le ce qu'on appelait à ce
moment-là le professionnel court ça a
changé depuis tout à l'heure alors il y
a les bonnes têtes de chapitre il y a
pas de problème
c'est pas sûr que on pourrait dire qu'il
y a réussi ou pas juste à partir de
cette aide au chapitre j'entends
rapidement
non et là toute la dynamique qui crée
les écoles à trois vitesses c'est quand
même le régime très particulier du
Québec sur le financement des écoles
privées qui fait que les écoles qui ne
le sont pas et qui sont publiques pour
faire concurrence au privé offre plein
de spécialités
c'est sûr que ça rend le cours plus
intéressant mais ça se fait quand même
au détriment de du grand nombre qui sont
dans le programme régulier qu'on
convient d'ailleurs de bêtises de façon
tellement péjorative stationnement dès
qu'elle parent va vouloir maintenant que
ses enfants soient dans ce programme-là
je soupçonne qu'on va reparler pas mal
sur d'éducation pour des prochains mois
passez la propriété du gouvernement le
groupe puis monsieur Drainville du pain
sur la planche cette semaine et ça aussi
on en parle souvent santé mais le jalon
a bougé encore un peu cette semaine vous
allez entendre une déclaration François
Legault puis je reviens avec vous à
Michel tout de suite après Justin a
raison c'est pas juste une question
d'argent mais
ce qui est important ce qui est de la
flexibilité parce que les provinces
chaque province est pas rendu au même
endroit puis à des priorités qui peuvent
être différentes de la flexibilité
Michel parce que Monsieur Trudeau a dit
cette semaine peut-être une entente
nationale puis ensuite des entent
individuel avec chacune des provinces
sur des éléments particuliers ensemble
vraiment avoir réussi à trouver une voie
de passage qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
d'après vous
je pense que l'opinion publique leur
clairement indiqué à tout le monde le
premier fédéral que il fallait qu'il y a
quelque chose qui se passe
dans l'émission de l'État les trois plus
grands la santé l'éducation que la
justice ça va pas très bien un peu
partout à ce moment ensemble à ce
moment-ci donc c'est un petit peu
difficile pour le gouvernement de dire
fédéral de dire
ceci cela et il va falloir avoir de la
flexibilité c'est toujours plus qu'à
manquer quand on a parlé d'éducation
alors à ce moment-ci donc il va être de
santé je veux dire et donc il va
peut-être être possible avec des
ententes particulières de de régler le
problème mais ce n'est pas
tant qu'on n'aura pas vu le montant tant
qu'on aura pas vu exactement ce que le
gouvernement fédéral va demander on peut
pas le savoir mais c'est vrai que ça
regarde bien c'est vrai que il y a
quelque chose qui se passe là parce que
tout le monde semble en tout cas il y a
clairement le temps à changer beaucoup
alecte depuis le début on est parti
devant couvert ou
tout le monde semble être capable de
s'asseoir ensemble pizza il y a intérêt
d'entendre est-ce que c'est réglé où il
y a encore des écueils potentiels que
Monsieur Trudeau vous ses collègues
devraient surveiller
on aime beaucoup tenté de minimiser les
attentes du côté d'Ottawa cette semaine
en disant vous savez c'est pas l'endroit
où Justin Trudeau va signer l'entente
avec les provinces soniques une
rencontre de travail entre les premiers
ministres provinciaux et le premier
ministre du Canada mais en même temps ça
ne peut pas être une réunion de travail
soyons honnête là si on sort de cette
rencontre là avec des gros titres dans
les médias dans les journaux aucun
progrès ou aucune entente ça va mal
paraître pour tout le monde autant pour
les provinces que pour le fédéral donc
je pense qu'il faut que les progrès soit
significatifs en sortant de cette
rencontre là je sais pas s'il l'entendre
va être signé mais faut qu'on soit très
très près d'une entente et qu'on puisse
le dire à la population parce que se
rencontrer pour parler pour parler là je
pense pas que la population canadienne
s'attend à ça de la part des premiers
ministres on va avoir un peu je pense
les couleurs de cette rencontre là
quelques jours avant quand Christian
freelen ministre des Finances vont
rencontrer ces hommes-là des finances de
3 février à Toronto elle elle les
rencontre pour dire voici ce que vous
allez obtenir en gros en termes de
transfert pour préparer vos propres
budgets si l'ouverture madame freelone
essayait de l'argent sur la table pour
la santé elle va ouvrir un peu son jeu
regardez voici les paramètres avec
lesquels on va discuter dans quelques
jours entre le Premier ministre Trudeau
et vos premiers ministres et là on va
savoir si on peut avoir quelque chose
d'assez concret si le 3 février tout le
monde sort mais content de la rencontre
avec Madame Freeland ça sera pas bon
signe pour la rencontre du 7 février
Chantal en même temps on a l'impression
que tout le monde a quelque chose à
peine de pas faire preuve d'un peu de
flexibilité
le temps du côté du ministre des
Finances que du côté des premiers
ministres de 7 février
c'est vrai tout le monde une obligation
de résultats pour des raisons
différentes les provinces et les
gouvernements fédérales mais moi j'en ai
découvert deux ça met du même genre
chrétien l'autre sous palmartin les deux
fois il y avait pas d'entente il restait
plus que juste sortir de communiquer ou
de s'entendre sur les virgules et les
deux fois le gouvernement du Canada et
le Premier ministre s'est fait tasser
dans un coin et a fini par être obligé
de mettre plus d'argent pour sortir avec
une entente alors on verra la dynamique
puis là je vous amène un petit peu
ailleurs parce que ça commence à faire
des bagues et ça de l'importance pour la
survie du gouvernement de sainte rideau
et c'est l'idée pour arriver à une
entente de Justin Trudeau de laisser
passer des initiatives qui envoient des
chirurgies au privé comme celles qu'on
voit en Ontario mais pas seulement ça
fait des vagues auprès du NPD mais cette
semaine ça commençait à faire des vagues
au sein de son propre prococus il y a
des députés ouvertement qui disent
je suis déçu que mon premier ministre
dit que c'était une sorte d'innovation
et je vous dirais que si j'étais dans le
bureau de Monsieur Trudeau je regarderai
ça parce qu'il y a des nuages qui
peuvent mener à des tempêtes qui ont
rien à voir avec son enfant avec les
provinces mais qui ont beaucoup à voir
avec l'avenir du gouvernement
innovation c'est le terme que Monsieur
Trudeau va utiliser dans une autre vue
avec votre collègue au star il y a une
semaine ça nous amène à la reprise des
travaux parlementaires on va beaucoup
parler de santé je présume on va
beaucoup parler de finances par la force
des choses parce que il y a un budget
qui s'en vient
ottawaï à Québec je vais commencer avec
vous Michel qu'est-ce que vous allez
surveiller sur les deux fronts vaut dans
le courant de la prochaine session
parlementaire
commençons par Québec il va falloir voir
ce qui va se passer avec les
initiatives que le gouvernement prend
c'est un site par exemple sur Auberge
vendredi matin qui a relancé le débat
sur la langue comme si la loi 96 avait
jamais existé c'est quand même assez
étonnant gouvernement a dit pendant
toute la campagne électorale on a
utilisé de la clause de rogatoire pour
pas pour montrer qu'il était important
puis pour pas la faire contester et là
on dit non seulement on commence le
travail et voici nos têtes de chapitre
mais monsieur salaire barrette qui était
le ministre de langue et pas dans le
comité de ministre qui va s'occuper de
la langue c'est un petit peu particulier
il faudra voir comment ça ça fonctionne
faudra aussi voir parce que
ça va être la première fois qu'on va
voir l'opposition en action est-ce que
par exemple le Parti libéral qui qui a
de gros problèmes actuellement on se le
cachera pas et capable de s'imposer
comme opposition officielle est-ce que
québeccident qui se voient déjà avec un
12e siège un peu prendre sa place
qu'elle va être la place du PQ qui est
très bon pour faire perdre de lui mais
une fois dans le contexte parlementaire
c'est plus difficile
ça ça va être aussi à surveiller
Ottawa je veux dire on va surveiller la
conférence sur la santé et le budget de
Madame prudent c'est les deux grandes
les deux grandes choses et j'entends
d'en parler la survie du gouvernement
combien de temps le NPD va encore aimer
ça
faut pas évident puis des choses
traditionnelles pour comme pour le NPD
comme ne pas avoir de privé dans la
santé ça risque de devenir un écueil
bon évidemment le budget fédéral pour
toutes ces raisons-là mais aussi pour la
capacité du gouvernement de continuer à
être concurrentiel dans les intentions
de vote on a vu les discours des deux
principaux chefs
pour préparer la rentrée est-ce qu'on
comprend c'est que les gants sont tombés
des deux côtés pierre poillière bon
étant en mode attaque on est habitué
mais Justin Trudeau qui est en mode
réplique ça suggère qu'il y a des
chiffres qui doivent déranger les
libéraux et en même temps le Parti
libéral le gouverne les libéraux ont
commencé et je suis bien une partie à
demander aux députés si ils avaient
l'intention de se représenter
la vérité c'est que quand on décide
qu'on se représente pas on se sent
beaucoup plus libre de parole et ça ça
pourrait avoir un impact sur la cohésion
du caucus de Monsieur Trudeau qui cette
semaine a suit des tirs nourris sur sa
gestion des finances publiques par des
gens qui sont totalement
identifiés aux parties libérales du
Canada effectivement alex je vous laisse
le mot de la fin à Québec ou Ottawa
qu'est-ce que vous allez surveiller vous
êtes semaine je vais suivre un dossier
partagé pendant toute la session qui est
celui de l'immigration
vous auriez pas totalement tort autant
ici que à mon émission j'en parle
souvent parce que c'est un dossier qui
est chaotique qui est partagé Québec
Ottawa puis là je parle pas uniquement
des demandeurs d'asile je mets Roxane
qui oui est un dossier très important je
parle aussi des visas pour les étudiants
francophones étrangers qui veulent venir
étudier au Québec à toute la question
également de
de l'avenir du français par
l'immigration presque 100% francophone
c'est les premiers pas de Christine
Frechette la nouvelle ministre de
l'Immigration du Québec a commencé cette
semaine à accorder ses premières
entrevues l'impression est bonne le ton
est bon c'est une femme de dossier
va-t-elle avoir l'ascendant sur ses
propres collègues au caucus et au
cabinet le goût pour imposer des
changements ce sera à voir et
chantefraiser que dire de chantefraser
le ministre fédéral de l'immigration si
ce n'est qu'il n'est qu'il est par son
absence au Québec un poids pour son
gouvernement le fait qu'il ne puisse pas
accorder d'entrevue en français alors
que tous les points chauds presque de ce
ministère là se trouve au Québec je
parlais du chemin Roxane le financement
des organismes communautaires à Montréal
sont qui sont débordés par les l'afflux
des demandeurs d'asile les Viso
francophones pour les étudiants
étrangers etc etc les travailleurs
étrangers
tout ça est au Québec mais il est
incapable de s'expliquer au point où on
est obligé de demander à Pablo Rodriguez
son ministre responsable au Québec ce
que vous lui parlez à Charles Fraser
est-ce qu'il est au courant que des
problèmes dans ce domaine-là au Québec
c'est pas normal alors je sais qu'il y a
pas de remaniement vu à Ottawa mais on
ne rend pas service actuellement à ce
dossier là au gouvernement Trudeau par
le vide créé par l'absence de ce
ministre là qui est incapable
d'expliquer si on fait quelque chose ici
même ça nous préoccupe ce qui se passe
en émigration au Canada on nous dit que
ça s'en vient l'entrevue en français
quand on nous dit qu'il travaille
là-dessus
je vous dis pas que ça règle l'ensemble
des choses mais bon il fait des petits
efforts avec Chantal Michel merci
infiniment la semaine prochaine au
revoir